ROBBIE: Hey, dad.
DAD: Why hi, son.
Something bothering you?
Your get up and go seems
to have got up and left.
ROBBIE: Eddie Clark
was making fun of me
today because he's got
CocoaPods in his Xcode project
and I don't have any.
What am I going to do?
DAD: Son, I think it's
time we had a talk.
You're getting
older now, and I'm
guessing you've started
noticing the allure
of certain
third-party libraries.
ROBBIE: AFNetworking has been
kind of nice to me lately.
And oh gosh, I guess I do
sort of like Google Analytics.
But I think I'd be too
scared to talk to them.
DAD: Son, I won't lie.
Integrating with a third-party
library, It isn't always easy.
You have to download
frameworks and bundles
and import them into
your Xcode project.
You probably need
to link your binary
and add a new iOS
linker flag or two.
And, well, heck, if
this library depends
on any other
frameworks, well, you're
going to have to do it all over
again with those libraries.
It wasn't that funny.
Anyway, keeping these things
up to date isn't easy either.
You have to go on
onto the internet
and see if anything has changed,
and repeat the whole process
all over again.
ROBBIE: Gosh, dad, that just
sounds like a bunch of work.
DAD: Well, there
are a lot of steps.
And if you're not
careful, you're
going to end up making
some pretty confusing
little mistakes, like this one.
Oh, instance 7fe5b1, I'm
sorry I let you down.
ROBBIE: Gee, dad, this
just sounds too scary.
Forget I even asked.
DAD: Well, not so fast, son.
You see, this is where
CocoaPods comes in.
CocoaPods is a dependency
manager written specifically
for adding third-party libraries
to your iOS application.
ROBBIE: Really?
Well, how does that work?
DAD: Well, come with me.
I'll show you.
So now you see, Robbie.
Oh, good thing I
have this on me.
The author of a library is going
to write a Podspec file that
specifies everything you
as a developer would need
to properly install it--
what files are required
and where they live,
what iOS libraries
you might need to
run it, if there
any pre or post-processing
stops, and much more.
Now, you as a developer
don't actually
need to care about most
of this, although I do
think it's interesting.
You just need to know the
name of this Podspec file,
and optionally, if
there's a specific version
you want to be using.
See, you're going to
create your own file,
called a Podfile, that lists
the names of the Podspecs
that represent the
libraries you want
to use with your application.
Then CocoaPods takes
care of the rest.
We here at Google
like it so much,
heck, you might even say
we're cuckoo for CocoaPods.
ROBBIE: I don't
get that reference.
DAD: You will in a few years.
We like it so much that
Google is now making it
the official way we distribute a
growing number of our libraries
to the world, including AdMob,
Google Sign-in, and Google
Analytics.
ROBBIE: Wow.
So how do we get started?
DAD: Well, Robbie,
perhaps the best way
to understand the
beauty of CocoaPods
is to see it for yourself.
Here, we'll use my laptop.
So Robbie, if you've never
used CocoaPods before,
the first step is to install it.
We're going to be
using the RubyGems
tool to install CocoaPods.
Yeah, that's right.
We're going to be using a
dependency manager to install
a dependency manager.
ROBBIE: It must go
deeper, huh, dad?
DAD: Yeah, that movie hasn't
been written yet, Robbie.
Anyway, go ahead and open up
your favorite terminal program.
iTerm2, good choice.
Now, the first thing
we want to do here
is make sure your Gems
tool is up to date.
So go ahead and type sudo
gem update - - system.
And you can enter
your password there.
ROBBIE: OK.
Hunter two.
DAD: That's your password?
All right.
Well, depending on how old
your version of Gems is,
it might need to
update some things.
But once that's done, you can
use Gem to install CocoaPods.
So you'll type sudo
gem install cocoapods.
And that will install
the CocoaPods tool.
This might take a while,
so don't worry if it
looks like your system is hung.
ROBBIE: Gosh, this is
taking a long time.
DAD: Yeah, it is.
Let's skip ahead here.
That's better.
Now, you're going to type
one more command here.
You're going to type pod setup.
And this is going to download
every single Podspec file,
over 8,000 of them, from the
official CocoaPods repository
to your machine.
Now, don't worry.
These automatically get
updated in the future,
so you only need
to do this once.
All right.
Once that's done,
we're ready to go.
Next, let's create a simple
application in Xcode.
Just go ahead and create a
simple single view application
here.
And now you can quit Xcode.
ROBBIE: Well, that was exciting.
DAD: Don't be a smart aleck.
Now we're going to navigate to
the project you just created.
You want to be in the same
directory as our Xcode project.
And here, we get to create
our very own pod file.
Now, we could have CocoaPods
create a slightly filled out
version for us by
typing pod init,
or we can start
with an empty file.
Let's do that
because it's easier.
So now go ahead and
edit this empty file.
And there are really only
a couple lines of text
you're going to
need to add here.
First, you need to tell CocaPods
pods what platform you're
running on by typing platform:
iOS, and then in quotes, "7.0."
And this says we're
building on iOS
and 7.0 is our
deployment target.
ROBBIE: Deployment target?
DAD: Right.
See, that's the
minimum iOS target
that your app is
going to support.
It's something every developer
sets in their Xcode project,
and we need to make
sure we list it here.
ROBBIE: Why?
DAD: Well, libraries
might only work
on certain versions of iOS.
You need to tell CocoaPods
the oldest version of iOS
your project is going to
support so that it can point out
problems to you ahead of time.
Now we can list the
podspecs we want to add.
Now what was that
delightful little library
you're keeping your eye on?
ROBBIE: Aw shucks,
it was AFNetworking.
DAD: Ah yes.
All right.
Well, let's add that one first.
Now, the thing is, we don't know
for sure what AFNetworking's
podspec is named.
There's no real
industry standard there.
Luckily, there are ways
to figure this out.
One way is to use the pod search
command from the command line.
So go ahead and type
pod search AFNetworking.
ROBBIE: Whoa.
That's a lot of results.
DAD: Well yeah, but it looks
like this first one is simply
called AFNetworking is
the one that we need.
ROBBIE: Well, what
are these others?
DAD: You mean things like
AFNetworking-Synchronous?
These are mostly
categories written
by other developers that
extend the capabilities
of AFNetworking.
But we just want the main
AFNetworking CocoaPod.
And as we can see
here, you can get that
by adding the line pod
afnetworking to our pod file.
ROBBIE: Oh, oh, can we
add Google Analytics next?
Can we?
DAD: Yes, yes.
Calm down, son.
Now, for Google
Analytics, I'll show you
how to search for
it another way.
We can open up our
browser to cocoapods.org
and in this big search bar at
the top, just type in Google
Analytics.
Well, this looks
like the one we want.
Now, it has this copy
to clipboard icon here.
So you can just select that.
And now you can paste this line
into your pod file as well.
ROBBIE: Say, wait a second.
What's that squiggly arrow mean?
DAD: Well, it gets complicated.
But you can think of it as
saying let's start with version
3.10, but feel free to update it
for me until you get to version
4.
ROBBIE: Sounds like a good
topic for a follow-up video.
DAD: You always
were a bright kid.
So let's go back to your command
line and type pod install.
Here we go.
You're going to see
CocoaPods think for a while.
Then it's going to go
out onto the internet,
grab the libraries that
we need, and install them.
We can wait a few more seconds.
And we're done.
ROBBIE: Say, what's this line
about using xcworkspace file?
What's that?
DAD: Well, an xcworkspace
file is basically
a collection of projects.
In this case, we have
our original project,
which is our empty application.
And then we also have
the Pods project,
which builds all of our
CocoaPods as static libraries.
ROBBIE: But I don't get it.
Why can't we just use
our original project?
DAD: Well, CocoaPods has
altered our original project
to rely on the static libraries
built by this other project.
So go ahead and open your
original project by itself
and try and run it.
See?
Xcode is complaining
that it doesn't
know what these libraries are,
and we get these fun linker
errors.
ROBBIE: Yikes.
DAD: Well, it's
not really too bad.
You just need to open
the workspace in Xcode
and build from there.
Once you do that, it builds the
static libraries and everything
works just fine.
ROBBIE: Oh, I see.
But if I tried to
reopen my old project
from the welcome screen--
DAD: That's right.
That, along with any
recent projects list,
it's probably a link
to your old project
that no longer works on its own.
ROBBIE: So is that it?
Can I use my libraries now?
DAD: You betcha.
Let's go back to your
view controller here.
You can import AFNetworking
and GIA, which stands
for Google Analytics Igloos?
ROBBIE: I don't think that's it.
DAD: No All right.
And in our viewDidLoad
method, you
can make calls on both
of these libraries.
And look at that.
Everything builds
and runs just fine.
We saved a whole
lot of manual steps
we normally would
have needed to include
both of these libraries.
And if you ever want to make
sure you're running the latest
and greatest of
any these pods, you
can simply type pod update
from the command line.
CocoaPods will check and see
if there are newer versions
of any these libraries.
If there are, it will
update them for you.
Since we just installed
everything a few minutes ago,
I would be surprised if this
command actually did anything.
But I'm sure you can imagine how
much work this would save you
on an actual project.
So there you go, son.
Everything you've always
wanted to know about CocoaPods.
ROBBIE: Gee, thanks, dad.
DAD: Now, when that Eddie
Clark starts teasing you again
at the school yard, what
are you going to tell him?
ROBBIE: I'm going to tell
him, hey Eddie, it was
me who set your car on fire.
DAD: You set his-- oh, Robert.